I feel like the writers on the show
wouldn't even get this quiz right this
is deep I'm your ugly Smith and I get
the voice of Lisa Simpson I am here to
answer some Simpsons trivia and we will
tell you if you're more Homer Bart Lisa
or Marge this is terrifying
which of these is an actual Malibu Stacy
doll I feel like I didn't even know
there was more than one disaster relief
telethon Stacy social-media influencer
Stacy that's just insane sound very Lisa
Simpson e Duff Beer special edition
Stacy there's truly Bella live from the
improv Stacy I'm gonna go with disaster
relief telephones Daisy ahh I am wrong
so the right one is live from the improv
Stacy dispatch is bad please don't let
this get out I'm gonna lose my job
what country did the insanity Pepper
Homer eight come from Costa Rica
Guatemala Cambodia Brazil I'm gonna go
with Guatemala we did make fun of Brazil
we made fun of Brazil so brutally that
the tourism office actually sued us the
problem is I don't even actually
remember this episode I'm gonna go with
my first thought I chose Guatemala which
famous actor voiced homers mother Mona
Simpson this is easy
Glenn Close Sally Field Meryl Streep
Diane Keaton all wonderful actresses it
happens to be Blake close her oh I
didn't have any interaction with Glenn
Close while she was doing Homer
Simpson's mother but I actually did a
play on Broadway with Jeremy Irons and
Glenn Close called the real thing and
she was so welcoming and so gracious to
me I never forgot it she really couldn't
have been nicer
which iconic singer hasn't been on the
show Lady gaga Dolly Parton Adele
Britney Spears well I met Lady gaga
I stood next to her she actually came
into the studio and recorded with us and
she stood right next to me I was kind of
a GOG I have to say and she was amazing
she was so humble and so lovely and she
was all in I'm gonna say Britney Spears
boo Adele Adele why aren't you been
our show we want you on our show
oh my god rats which of these is not the
name of a seven Duff's mascot Spinney
surly tipsy queasy I want to say spinny
[Music]
alright you're going to start to call me
an impostor by the way I didn't even
know there were seven doves in the max
power episode which Disney princess
movie song did Homer want to say with
Marge really so the choices are
Cinderella Beauty and the Beast The
Little Mermaid Sleeping Beauty and I
feel like I can hear in my head
dan Castellaneta who does the voice of
Homer singing Beauty and the Beast so
I'm gonna choose that okay I'm wrong I
swear to God I could hear Dan as Homer
seeing Beauty and the Beast
that's Lisa Simpson singing yeah but
okay okay let's get out not that I don't
love Marge but it says I'm the most like
Marge which means I'm not the most like
Lisa which means I don't I don't know
what to do I'm gonna cry I don't think
Lisa would be at all bothered that she's
most like her mother all I can tell you
is that now you're gonna make me cry
Lisa Simpson is such a deep genuine part
of me I am so pleased and proud to be a
part of her heart and soul I don't need
a funny silly game to tell me whether or
not
Lisa Simpson lives inside of me but this
was really fun thank you
[Music]